the uh rams on now she has been for
years but anyway so we were there last
night
and uh and you know who strolled into
the suite
pro football hall of famer marshall
faulk
um and to make sure that he could not
leave uh it was susie's job to make sure
that he cannot leave
this will be a fun photograph uh the
thursday after the super bowl when
they're co-hosting this show together i
know
he's a pro football hall of famer one of
my favorite people on the planet he's
marshall funk how are you marshall
i'm doing good rich how are you baby
how's it going that's fine susie uh made
sure you were not leaving the suite
because you know you you light
man-to-man coverage bump and run it was
definitely it's definitely a five-yard
penalty there's no question about that
yeah that's getting flagged
um why did the rams win that game last
night in your estimation
literally
uh the the trades that they made all
three all three
uh all through i should say all three
moves that they made
uh stafford in the fourth quarter when
you look at the numbers he made the
throws that garoppolo didn't he made the
throws that at time
jared golf would make
um
when they took when they took cup away
obj made himself available
and then we we we saw we saw a bar
miller on the other side of the ball the
complimentary um they couldn't just they
couldn't just double team aaron donald
and maybe slide and chip floyd
oh man it was uh all the moves you know
that left that they've made this season
um and this off season
they all
they all roost they all roost it was
just it was perfect
and um and you know i guess there was
that moment in time that ball was in the
air where
the maybe the the the one mistake you'd
make obviously i'm not staring at all
22s but the one mistake the actual
terrible mistake only one of the
postseason that stafford made throwing
one up for grabs that uh that tart of
san francisco just had the proverbial
hands-like feet
could have picked that one off and
didn't and that right there is when i
thought even though you know it was a
10-point deficit this could actually be
the rams night when i saw something like
that oh that that was that that was like
the one throw that i saw carelessness
with and you know i've i've been i've
been tough on staffer like i'm i'm i put
it out there i felt like i was like man
i don't know is it detroit or what the
staffer but throughout these playoffs
rich he's um
you know he showed me what i needed to
see that he's capable of taking care of
the football and not not needing to be
the hero just being the quarterback who
win the game and not caring how it
looked you know but that one throw i i
mean even the throw went on the
interception you know the one that was a
little behind cup god made a good play
you know ball got pop ball got tip tip
drill interception
i was i was actually okay with that play
you know but
other than the throw up the i mean he's
been he's been dynamic like i'm i'm i'm
serious i'm impressed i did not know
that this guy existed in matthew
stafford i'll be honest no i just didn't
rich wow so he has officially won you
over
you're saying
he's yeah he has shown me that he's
capable of playing you know all these
quarterbacks they can play in the
regular season but you get them in in
the postseason and it's and it's
different
and it's it's the difference in the home
in the first in the homes in the first
half and the homes in the second half my
homes in the second half was like it was
a regular season game
and like cincinnati was just going to
lay down no
no that he lost focus
yeah
marshall faulk here on the rich eyes and
[ __ ]
let's switch gears then real quick to
that
um
you said mahomes treated the second half
like
repeat that one more time let's get to
my homes there and what you thought yeah
what happened with kansas city the
second half of that game you know that
they're up 21-3 and in cincinnati didn't
look good
um the second half he he got he got a
little relaxed
it was like it was like they have
another game to play if they lose this
one
he wasn't playing like this was it
how does something like that happen
it just it does i'm telling you it does
i mean the first half he wasn't running
around he was running up in there when
he had to scramble getting the two to
three or four or five yards making plays
and then all of a sudden he started he
started doing the dancing around you
know like like like his offensive line
like last year when his offensive line
was bad what he had to do and he didn't
have to do that
i mean
case in point those three points
that they that
there's no way you throw that ball with
tyree kill at the end of the first half
and andy listen andy's always going to
try to jump on the sword but muhammad is
not like a first or second-year guy like
this is
he's been there done that
you cannot complete that ball
knowing that your guy can't get out of
bounds or
you know stop the club you can't do that
he he knew better and he said i got
greedy you can't do that well the second
half was more of that it did seem that
way it did seem like you know um
the bengals were kind of daring him to
do the big play stuff right by putting
eight
eight um in coverage sometimes just
rushing three guys
and and and daring him to you know
to be the the big play guy when they're
they're basically showing him
to just keep making that profit and
matriculate the ball down the field and
and he dropped the football a couple
times i mean it was just wild to see
that happen marshall i just i i could
not it just it looked like one of those
one of those
actually it looked like early in the
season we were questioning was the major
magic gone
and they tighten it up that focus came
back and you saw you saw the the chief
that we know of and then
it just it came back do you think the
mat i mean
look i mean
the mystique there there is something
that comes with that word when you you
know when it's used certainly now when
the afc is now being reconfigured after
two decades of brady right and him being
out of the conference for two years now
and maybe out of the league
but um
that he
that this is a reordering of things
and the fact that mahomes has made it to
four conference championship games is
remarkable
but as a 50 hit rate on making the super
bowl and only one w in the case do you
think
that this uh mystique
has taken an irreparable hit
not sure
no i i don't think so rich i think it's
just uh there's a learning process to
what you learn about playing in this
league and not taking it for granted i
mean the dan marino will tell you that
uh jim kelly will tell you that and and
he will he will definitely
um evaluate his play in that second half
uh that that that the throw that he made
at the end of the second quarter and in
the second half he will evaluate his
play
and um and and he'll he will be better
he will be better marshall faulk here
pro football hall of famer here on the
rich eisen show uh one of the story
lines
that i think you're going to be hearing
a lot about over the next two weeks
certainly if brady does make his
announcement official and the brady
nostalgia will be in full bloom
that joe burrow will have um a long two
weeks or we'll we'll hear for two weeks
joe burrow is the next brady potentially
you know a quick ascendancy possibility
to win it all taking on the rams and in
the super bowl so on and so forth do you
buy any of that
marshall i think
i think i think the comparison
it's it's not just to play in like
regardless of what happened you get sack
mad times you usually lose let's be
honest but it's you just don't win games
when you get sacked nine times but he
has like that it factor and the people
around him
they elevate
for him
for some reason and
and um
you know i i literally said i'm like
rich he's not an average joe
he's more in the joe montana
more in the joe namath mold like he's
not just an average joe you know and he
has he has a little something about him
and um and you just you you like it
you like it i mean the guy has the
cincinnati bingos in the super bowl
that does actually say it all right
marshall just yes
and it's not like
you gotta take
you go through cleveland's supposed to
be the front runner in the super bowl
baltimore and pittsburgh
to get there
you beat the chiefs twice
like
they didn't take the easy path
the titans
no easy path think about what they've
done
it is incredible i guess it's it's lucky
for the bengals that burrow didn't tell
them draft a defensive lineman i'm not
coming right marshall
right i mean
listen to
for instance i just i just said just
just as a for instance you know i know i
know i know
[Laughter]
i want to i want to i want i literally
dusted off like my old card of me yes um
you know being photographed in a bengals
uniform and what could have been um and
then i just like you know okay they're
in the super bowl right i like it
they've arrived rich
i have to give them some listen man what
they've built
and i i heard somebody say something
last night that was like
relevant
when you look at when you look at their
team
they're built around players who have
played big time college games and the
stage wasn't too big
when you think about burrow
chase
higgins
like these dudes played in big games man
big games on the on the big stage in
college football and and the stage
wasn't too big in the league
sort of like michigan in the big ten for
tom brady yeah you know
[Music]
no
no no no he had five times as many
passing yards as drew henson his senior
year where he beat alabama in the orange
ball to walk out the door and somehow
somewhere you fell to 199. marshall
let's just say this if tom was at
michigan right now he would have been in
the portal just like joe
don't go albert breer on me marshall
at ohio state
never go full breer marshall you know
that that's good never go
what are you doing no
please
like don't you know like ohio state is
like hold on wait
who was better than joe girl
dwayne haskins
dwayne haskins but he threw 50 he threw
50 while joe won 60. you know what i'm
saying so hey man i'm just saying
i'm just thinking um obviously you got
to have an eye for you got to have an
eye for talent
to miss joe burrow like you got to have
a really good eye for talent to miss joe
is your first is your first ever
quarterback in the pros going to leave
michigan to go coach the vikings
marshall what do you think
i i just can't see i listen michigan has
stuck by him through dick and ben i
can't see him leaving them high and dry
right now
i just can't see that
like i feel like i know enough about
about jen that
he entertained did what he needed to do
and i know some people feel like oh he's
not paying attention but i think when
you find out what he turned down to
remain at michigan it's going to say
he's all in with michigan
okay
um that would be great for me i'll buy
that and uh what do you think marshall
falk
the niners and their brass coach lynch
are thinking about jimmy garoppolo this
morning
what do you think not
what do you mean they're not they they
already know like like this
this was it for jimmy like this
that's a wrap
i'm i'ma be honest i
jimmy
you were standing next to me and i was
like okay here it is
now he's about jimmy g is about to show
up
some some people can handle the pressure
and some can't
and and when it gets thick
whether it's the ball
the touchdown to emanuel standards that
he missed in a super bowl or against the
chiefs or
you know some of the throws that i mean
that game should have been out of here i
i i never seen jaylen ramsey drop a ball
to hit him in the
chest i mean it just he cannot handle
the pressure right now he had kettle
what how to he had kettle open right uh
obviously he hit him for the touchdown
but he had kittle open for a touchdown
in the first quarter i mean that was
right there
you know
it's rich it is what it is man you
either can handle those moments and you
can't i don't want to take anything away
from the guy i just don't i don't feel
like he's built to handle the moments
would you go and hire him if you were a
gm somewhere else and you know if let's
just say you're pittsburgh looking for
the the
the guy after roethlisberger let's just
say you're yeah anybody looking for you
you would take i'd bring him i'd bring
him in he'd be my backup
yeah
maybe you're my backup he would yeah so
you would not hire him as a starting
quarterback no
no no
uh-huh he but he looked he looked real
handsome holding the clipboard really
good wow
really good
i'm all for i'm all for him rich i love
the guy he can't win 10 games in
pittsburgh next year
you have the rumor with that division
there's there's good quarterbacks on on
well
somewhat you know cleveland if the
jury's still out on baker i i don't know
if it's baker or if it's the system i
can't figure it out
um
but uh
yeah well i don't know in terms of that
marshall
the fact that odell is balling out right
now
wha what are what what would you counsel
brown's fans to be thinking
seeing that
marshall well i don't think that was
baker's fault i think that was the fans
fault
you know this this wasn't the first time
stefanski was the guy with digs as well
you know this this is not this is not
the first time he's isolated that kind
of receiver a guy who wants leads he's
done this before
what is this what is that what did you
put more meat on the bones of what the
this is
well you isolate a receiver out a guy
who demands the ball wants the attention
and and whom you they may have thought
he was a distraction yeah
yeah i mean you you feature you feature
and you listen here here's what
sean mcvay it's it's all it's a cooper
cup show
but he'll feature odell on drive
don't feature old
first snap of the game last night was a
quick throw to odell first snap there
you go yeah
yes
and and you know some coaches are
creative enough to do that and some they
just they just run a system
and maybe maybe we'll maybe maybe it's
the fans
he'll get his guy
and uh and uh kirk cousins you know to
come run his offense and
you know
show that he's actually
you know worth worth what they paid him
and why they hired him but
i just don't i don't i don't
listen odell's in the super bowl right
now let's just say that
i could see that by the way i i am
fluent in martial faulk um
uh christopher t.j i am fluent in
martial faulk inflection
um that's that that was a passive
aggressive shot at uh kirk cousins
right there
i can't i cannot imagine kirk cousins
quarterback in the minnesota vikings
next year
so that's why you bring them in for
cleveland so what you're saying yeah you
bring them in for cleveland
jimmy g or kirk cousins marshall
uh i'm going kurt cousins kurt has a
bigger body of
bad work so i'm gonna go
yeah
yeah
ladies and gentlemen hall of famer
marshall falk to play us out
thanks marshall it's great seeing you
last night all good man always take care
love you brother hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here